c'est important pour nous d'être élégant
loi nome
non
pas du tout
alors pourquoi vous avez choisi de
l'être je cherche du travail well and
associe alors là moi voyez vous
j'ai ma mode à moi bonjour monsieur
bonjour madame vous avez beau chapeau à
je dis chapeau chez moi c'est vous oui
et ce par dessus
c'est moi aussi et la cravate c'est moi
également
mais l'aurait parié bien sûr y côté
votre femme à la maison elle atténue
ménagères
ouais c'est vous qui vous occupez de
garde-robe de votre mari pourri un petit
peu parce que j'ai un fils mais enfin
mon fils à 50 50 50 ans alors par tête
qui me dis qu'il vaut mais parce que moi
je me rends pas compte quand elles sont
un peu usé là bien sûr oui d'ailleurs
même je peux lui acheter un costume
cintré et moi oui j'en ai acheté un en
velours est lui tombé parfaitement bien
aucun problème qui a choisi vos
vêtements à qui nous avions je peux dire
je m'en veux les chemises ma femme je
viens avec lui pour choisir
mais négatif aubin l'écossé où j'ai
choisi avec lui
[Musique]
normalement et quand je veux un pantalon
me plaît je lui dis c'est que lui n'a
pas tellement bijoux alors paul d'idées
c'est moi qui m'occupe de la gare
d'euros moi même vous même s'il vous qui
vous aviez en général oui mais je
demande l'avis de ma femme après katrina
près
juste avant le dernier essayage
on doit donner quand elle m'accompagne
donne sens gourmet capsule tout seul il
y en a mieux dire pour moi je craque et
d'arguer vêtements des briquets et blanc
oh la la
en témoin absolument ben voilà
choisissez vous même vos victoires même
avec les deux parents
mais votre maman de ma mère
exactement là je tiens beaucoup à l'aide
de ma mère mais
elle me donne quelques conseils mais
souvent je passe outre et je fais
il faut répondre à ça
je crois qu'ils comptent pas beaucoup
non elle
n'a pas d'opinion là dessus est-ce que
tu enfin il vous arrive de donner votre
avis bien sûr toujours même et d'écouté
oui assez souvent en général
non il a des goûts très personnel c'est
par là
si si c'est bien ou mal
il encore le faire ensemble c'est tout
mais ce n'est pas à elle seule
il est toujours content je connais ses
goûts j'essaie de quelques fois je
triche âme que je rapporte ce qu'il a
pas envie de m me lever quand même oui
et puis janot très fiers l'écouté il va
tout de suite qui a l'entière
responsabilité finalement votre garde
robe
peut pas dire oui parce qu'à ce train
arrière
oui mais un petit peu les hommes n'ont
pas beaucoup de goût pour les femmes et
vice versa vous aimez comme ça vous
l'avez trouvé pas canada chez moi
montréal
vient d'angleterre
le couturier du tout ma femme assistait
à c'est votre femme quasi injuste et oui
comme en autriche
qui est-ce qui choisiront de papillons
eux
généralement mois accessoirement les
filles mais je n'ai pas cessé sa taille
et sa longueur de pantalons et les
crottes non parce qu'il a tellement
mauvais goût qu'elle soit blessée
t'es pas tout seul c'est vous qui avez
choisi aujourd'hui vous habiller avec
une chemise rayée bleu et blanc ce qui
est très joli et quelque chose de
plaisant à cravate
oui pourquoi c'est un peu par hasard je
prends la première chemise qui sort de
l'art moi c'est moi qui ait choisi notre
dame
qu'est-ce qui a choisi cette casquette
chez moi la fin ne rend pas le pas
demande toujours conseil au bon
comportement dans le but de plaire à la
femme comme la femme dans le but de
plaire à l'homme je trouve que c'est
important vous habillez vous
l'ambiance raquette
c'est important que d'hommes sont
élégants oui
o'keefe les acquis bashung à lui à moi
comme je peux
au très important pour moi pourquoi
parce que je comprends pas le mètre
carré
général délégué
ouais
liger n'est jamais très agréable à voir
et parce que ça me satisfait
personnellement et puis
je crois que on doit vivre dans
l'harmonie avec soi même d'abord fond
clair aux autres ensuite chacun ses
goûts du national sera le moyen de
se permettre de toujours
j'ai pas les moyens de payer un costume
si j'avais les moyens
non
au rez de chaussée vous payez
[Musique]
j'ai pris ça
ils sont beaucoup plus décontractée et
nous on est nettement plus sophistiqués
y avait une recherche que nous on essaye
de trouver
est ce que vous êtes content de ce que
vous offre madame ce qu'ils achètent
madame
certainement moi je ne serai plus avec
elle et il est content de vous attend ya
27 ans que ça dure
merci madame
[Musique]